[Music]
thank you for being here nice to have
you on the show you know i just saw a
picture of you the other day you you you
were at the met ball this was a huge
event yeah they call it the the uh the
oscars of fashion the oscars of fashion
you attend this event where was the
event again it was
the the met ball it's the met ball it's
at the metropolitan metropolitan museum
yes okay so uh uh good question conan uh
that's the name i'm sorry it was at
madison square okay guys shut up
i got distracted by you um
i saw a photograph of you in this dress
where it looks like you've been dipped
in liquid gold can we show this dre it's
absolutely stunning it's it's it
actually kind of was it was so
form-fitted it was made of a gold med
vintage gold metal and it was just it
was so it's really made of metal yeah
actually how do they get you into that
thing
uh they
i probably shouldn't say they they sewed
me into it they on the day of they had
to literally show me into it so that
everything fit perfectly in the right
spots and then they send me off and
and it was great and it was beautiful um
but they uh they didn't and this isn't
the first time for the emmys last year i
wore a red dress and they were so tight
they sewed you into it and it was so
tight around the knees and and
you kind of forget that after a certain
point you you kind of have to go you
gotta go and when you do and
i i tried to hold it in for so long i
mean i'm telling you like i was
like oh this is great when's it gonna be
over this just seems this just seems
medieval to me that they sew you into a
dress and there's no there's no uh way
that you can use a bathroom or anything
if you have your hands eventually you
have to and i and i asked them like what
do i do what do i do i could go gotta go
it's like you're like you know what when
it when the time comes you call the
designer and they have an emergency
sewing kit they cut you out of it
and then they'll sew you back in
so just so you can quickly you that's
ridiculous
the things you ladies have to do is it's
insane yeah so so there's someone there
and you have to tell them i must use the
bathroom sometime the next 40 minutes
and they tear the dress apart at some
point you just look you poke you right
on your phone you're like it's go time
now right
it's go time